arrête de klaxonner à chaque fois va pas
on dira mongolien moi aussi je suis
contente de voir mais on n'est pas
obligé de partager notre bonheur avec
tout le monde je vais prendre deux tomes
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma dame
ça s'appelle la division du travail elle
sourit elle parle très amusant by nico
est attendue est ce que ton père aimait
la crème que j'ai prescrite à shell va
j'en ai fait des champignons partout
cette gêne pas toi je vais te refaire
une bonne pélémois de champignons tu vas
vaut laisser un effort maintien on
échange des familles arrêtent ne
mangeait plus 4 on vient d'apprendre que
je reprends pour deux ans ou faire
chanter une chorale d'escalopes année on
veut s'attaquer au niveau parce que
quand tout va mal il n'y a plus aucun
espoir
il reste michel femme peut-être ici un
truc plus moderne
michel sardou est à la variété française
ce que mozart est à la musique classique
intemporel
je veux sentir la luxure le stupre ça
vous est jamais arrivé de boutonner
arrête un peu avec ton parigot bientôt
bella dans twilight vous avez redon ça
vous dirait d'aller apprendre le chant
paris
c'est l'école qui avarie
où
comment s'organiser la faire le marché
faut réfléchir à une autre solution
je sais ce que ça représente [ __ ] tu
es ma meilleure amie et un bon j'arrête
pourquoi ça je fais ce que je veux a
lancé ma vie vous êtes sûr que c'est
l'autre vit maintenant à tout de suite
mes chers parents je pense que madonna
tour je vous dis des faits mais je pas
vous n'aurez plus d'enfants
mauvaise mère au contraire tu es la mère
de tout mon bref je n'en suis pas
so fumée mais sans alcool je vaux
à cheval